and Uranus. We're all going to a
line right after sunset and be
visible to the naked eye. No
telescope required. Joining us
now to talk about the planets.
Aligning is the professor of
astrophysics at the university
of Rochester. Adam frank Adam. I
mean, I love the smithsonian
described this as a parade in
the western sky. What are we
gonna see? How cool is this
gonna be? Basically you're going
to be able to see the
architecture of the solar
system. You're going to see the
fact that all the planets all
orbit around the sun in a giant
pancake, and so that line up
that you're going to see on the
western sky right after sunset
is the fact that all the planets
right now are in a position on
that pancake that they're all
gonna basically line up so
you'll have Mercury Jupiter and
then uh, Venus Uranus is gonna
be a little hard to see without
binoculars and then Mars as
well. So you know, you're gonna
really see where we live. It's
listen. You know, there's an old
saying that my goodness the
planets were aligned. And it
means something big and great
and good. What does this mean?
And I know it doesn't happen
very often often. Does it
happen? And what is this? What
is the enormity of this? Sir.
The enormity is like coolness,
basically, like, you know, from
a cosmic perspective, these
things aren't really that rare
getting some of the planet
because they are all the
planets. Are we all orbit in one
giant Frisbee, so it's not
uncommon to get the plus some of
the planet's to align this one
because you're getting so many
of them. Aligning is a little
bit more rare, but it's more
just to see where we are. I
mean, it's you know what's
amazing is we've lost the night
sky. There's this guy is so
bright now with lights that we
don't get to see the planet. But
our ancestors even 200 years ago
, they noticed that the planets
were moving around against the
fixed stars, and it freaked him
out. It was a show and so for us
to be able to be reminded that
we live in a in a solar system
that we live in on a rock that
sterling with a bunch of other
rocks around this giant flaming
ball is a really powerful
reminder of just how profoundly
beautiful and mysterious the
world is given that quickly.
What is the easiest way to see
it tonight? What? You just walk
outside, or is there like a
certain place? You should go?
What is the easiest way to see
it when this happens? You want
to go someplace right after
sunset, where you get a good
view of the western sky because
Venus and Mercury going to be
pretty close to the horizon, and
they're gonna set pretty close.
Um I'm sorry. Jupiter and
Mercury Venus will be higher in
the sky, so you'll be able to
see it for longer than
eventually Mars and the moon.
You'll be able to see those as
well, but you want to clear view
of the western guy. If you have
binoculars, then you'll probably
also be able to make out Uranus
as well. In some place where
there's not a lot of light
pollution someplace. That's you
know. Where it gets dark, and
you don't have better. Yeah the
darker the sky's the better the
show. Right frank. Thank you so